what a great way for me to introduce my
next guest here from the Los Angeles
Times and I appreciate by the way he
offered to conduct this interview
because the LA Times offices are right
across the street when when things are
back to normal here again and instead of
whatever your you guys are doing these
days during the first 15 20 minutes of
our show or first hour of the show and
hardly paying attention to what I'm
saying and there are people walking
behind me and the you're distracted by
the people walking behind me percent but
everybody's back here again full strong
knock on what if you're with me when the
AT&T comes back full straight of yeah so
the Canyon of Heroes is you like to talk
about many times the LA Times members of
the Los Angeles Times will come and use
our cafeteria yes okay
so this gentleman offered to conduct
this interview on the other side in
person but through the glass practice
social distancing and we just said a
phone call will do because after 60
seconds that might just get a little odd
a little bit awkward but this means he's
just next-level columnist and a reporter
from the Los Angeles Times
he's a rosh mikaze how are you rush
cafeteria great salad bar we don't have
the cafeteria we're under construction
across the street but yep I did offer
you know with my masks and gloves to do
the social distancing segment I know I
was told that would not make good yeah
yeah it's just it's just I think I think
this is just appropriate to talk about
what's going on let's let's just jump
headfirst right into this Arash because
so many of us are hoping that sports
comes back all the headlines about you
know people who are sick and death
totals and it's just it really is so
depressing and it really gets to you and
that's why you know we're doing a show
like this everyday to at least get
people's minds off of that but the
concept of when sports is returning
obviously has a lot to do with that and
the conversation is already out there
that it won't
matter if sports leagues say we're gonna
come back and there are no fans that the
state of California is just gonna put
the kibosh on it anyway what are you
hearing on that front I mean the
conversation is really around what state
could we go and have these games at you
know whether it's Florida whether it's
Phoenix whether it's somewhere else
California I don't see that happening
and even when you talk about sports with
no fans that's the stage for three we're
in stage one now so I don't think we're
going to be in stage three soon so
that's why you're hearing about you know
Florida like Orlando Las Vegas you know
that being said rich I do think it would
be cathartic and calming to see sports I
know it's weird with no fans but I mean
if we're watching a game and it's a
competitive game and there's two teams
that we know again we have to wait till
it's safe we have to wait till they can
test everyone but when we get to that
point in time because I've heard so many
people talk about well if there's no
fans that's not gonna feel right well
listen we have to we have to just like
accept that things are not going to be
normal for a period of time but if we
can get sports back without fans I would
love that
of course and I'm reading all sorts of
polls that most sports fans would be
absolutely fine with with with no sports
fans in the stands that the sporting
events would go on and as everybody can
stay healthy and compete and and we can
see all this that's why I guess people
were staying up last night to watch
South Korean baseball on on ESPN nosh
you know oh by the way one of the
benefits of being in Los Angeles that is
a 10:00 p.m. start time not one o'clock
in the morning so I did watch KBO I will
be watching that and again that goes
back to I'm gonna watch you guys for the
for the schedule release the reoperation
again because I have nothing else to do
you know and so whether it's the draft
whether it's the last dance no matter
what it is like I'm kind of stuck at
home so I'm gonna watch what I can watch
right
let me get on a few items that you've
been hitting lately and your your
columns and that also dovetails a little
bit in and your articles and dovetails a
little bit of what we discussed already
just up the street is that brand new
stadium in which the Chargers and maybe
Justin Herbert and the Rams and
obviously a team that is a couple years
removed from the Super Bowl and we're
one year removed from a Super Bowl here
in the 2022 calendar year is when it
would be held here what's going on with
that stadium well from what I've heard
it's on track to be completed this
summer that being said rich we obviously
know that we won't be in a state in the
cat in the state of California to have
fans for positive co vid 19 cases on the
construct on the construction site that
continues by the way that's not uncommon
you go to Las Vegas they've had 16
confirmed cases so in construction
continues on both sites I've been told
that they both will be completed by this
summer but again I don't think we're
going to be in a place where we can have
fan so maybe games are held there
without fans you know you could insert
your own Chargers joke there but I don't
think both of those stadiums will be
done but I don't think either stadium is
going to be in a place to have 70,000
people soon okay and and what are you
hearing about the Lakers in the return
of the NBA Mirage that one to me which
seems like the most likely short-term
scenario why because I think you go
right into the postseason you've you've
played about 66 games you go back to the
little hockey out season in 2011-12 that
was 66 games you go back to the 99
lockout season that that was 50 games
they played about 66 games you go
straight into the playoffs 16 teams with
beauty of the playoffs is once the first
round is done you cut that number in
half you get to the second round you cut
that number in half so you have a
one-month postseason and you crowned the
champion and I think we're talking about
football and baseball when I think VNL
these guys have a training camp they've
had preseason they've played like 80
percent of their season they should find
a way to crown a champion so they're
cautiously optimistic you talk to Mark
Cuban you talk to other people in the
league cautiously optimistic that
there's no rush it doesn't have to be in
June maybe July but they want to find a
way a pathway to crowd at least a
champion okay Arash McCarthy of the Los
Angeles Times here on the Rich Eisen
show you had a great column about them
famed Monte Carlo practice that we saw
on the last dance on Sunday with Magic
Johnson being at the center of all that
I'm loving this man I'm wonder what else
you might be able to add from what we
saw on on Sunday night so when I posted
magic again you talked to guys on that
92 dream team they say that Monte Carlo
scrimmage is the greatest game that they
were a part of that to be played and
they loved it so much and I said well
you didn't you notice something he's
like yet but there were no fans there I
know it's different it's a scrimmage but
what you said is like listen if they
have the Western Conference Finals and
if the Lakers and the Clippers and he
got quiet Paul George and LeBron and I'm
Anthony Davis it's gonna be weird
without fans but you go a couple minutes
into that game and there's a big block
or there's a big shot your competitive
juices start to flow and and it's gonna
be fun to watch why is it gonna be fun
to watch we're gonna hear a lot of
trash-talking there may have to be a
10-second delay cuz they're give me a
lot of things that that we made I want
to hear and so he said it's not like an
ideal situation but when you talk about
the stakes being that high the NBA
Finals the conference championship game
if they played those games without fans
it may look weird but 5-10 minutes in
those competitive juices get to go and
you start trash-talking you start to
hear things he thinks it could be
fantastic I'm hearing is it true that
Kobe's last season his final season was
also chronicled like this that is he had
the camera crew there that entire season
and the one thing I kept thinking
throughout that season I think they only
won 13 games or something I said this is
really great content but it's during a
really bad season thankfully they were
there that night he scored 64
so they may have to do similar to what
they've done with the little hash dance
where you know it's chronicling his last
game and last season but you kind of go
back and forth because again that Allah
last season unfortunately was not a
great season but that 60 point night was
one of the most fun nights that I've had
yeah I mean that was I remember Arash I
was sitting at home with my wife and it
was a night where the Warriors were
going for the wind that would break the
day that's right the famed Bulls regular
season win total and it was also Kobe's
final final game and I remember that the
Warriors victory wasn't in doubt at all
and Kobe and the Lakers we're losing I
believe to the Jazz by double digits and
we're like just you know what screw it
let's just see let's see how this thing
plays out here in Staples and then our
jaws hit the floor that was one of the
most amazing because the number of times
that you are looking forward to seeing
something and the sporting event or the
athlete who's at the center of the
sporting event never rarely rarely rises
to the occasion rarely gives you what
you're looking for and and Kobe did that
that was and it was totally out of the
blue and it was amazing
amazing they showed that recently and as
fun as it was at the time it's really
heartbreaking in hindsight because Kobe
is there in GG and Vanessa and Gianna
are courtside and so when you watch that
back again and as soon as the game is
over he gives them a big hug and a kiss
and it's just heartbreaking but I mean
I'm glad that the Chronicle that last
night that last game is so they probably
have great stuff and I think this is
going to become a trend I think you're
going to see a lot of teams and players
say like I want people to remember me
like this listen no one's Michael Jordan
but I think maybe this may inspire more
people to say hey listen I want to be
chronicled like this Arash mikaze of the
Los Angeles Times here on the Rich Eisen
show if there's a documentary about the
Kobe Shaq ears what would that look like
do you think that would be amazing I
mean the drama so I mean the drama was
very
similar to this because I go back to
that 2004 finals and no matter what
happens because people think if they had
beaten Detroit that team was done Phil
was done coaching Kobe Shaq was done
with Co because obviously if you
remember that season begins with the
incident in Colorado and Shaq's
basically saying what the heck is going
on I mean the drama around that team so
that's what makes a great documentary as
if you have drama and that 2014 which
was one of my first seasons covering
them I just remember like what is going
on like none of this makes sense like in
terms of like no matter what happened
like Kobe's gone if Shaq's back so like
Kobe Michael the Clippers and Phil's
gone regardless and Carmelo what's he
gonna do and so I just that whole Kobe
Shaq relationship and you know one of
the you know the saddest things of Kobe
being gone is like you know he would not
hold back you know so he would have
given you a great sit-down interview so
I hope they do that because the
relationship that they had and how
contentious it was that's fascinating
well I mean obviously you know Shaq and
Kobe --zz relationship it could be you
know that I think there might be enough
material that's already out there prior
to okay and again I still can't believe
when Kobe's just brought up and just
seeing how a Episode five of the last
dance started with the you know in
loving memory of Kobe Bryant in the 1998
NBA all-star game in New York City it
just I still can't believe he's gone but
Phil I mean what is it about Phil that
allows him to coach such incredible
personalities and in the middle of what
appears to be pure hatred amongst
teammates people that he needs to
amazing because in today's time period
if a GM had made the decision to move on
from a coach I think we would all
wink-wink know that but I don't think he
I mean journey cross was very blunt like
he doesn't matter if he wins every
single game by 20 points like he's gone
just like they kind of like like
concerted drama and controversy maybe
that helped that that team but to go
back to Phil
I covered that Lakers team in 99 when
they got swept out of the second round
by the Spurs and who comes in and it's
basically the the same team I mean they
they really signed a bunch of guys who
were kind of like glue guys they brought
in Harper they brought in John Salley
they brought in Shaw but it wasn't like
they brought a superstar in but films
call me presents and the way that he
deals with guys and makes them play like
as one so whenever he's criticized is
like well he had Jordan and then he had
Kobe yes but he got them to play within
the construct that cut of a team and
that is HUGE Arash mikaze here on the
Rich Eisen show so I guess summing it
all up when it all comes down to it and
and we're gonna get Shaq on the question
I think that's gonna linger when this is
all said and done is the Bulls versus
the Lakers the the the dynastic teams
and who would be better than the other I
think we're gonna get to that
that's my when people say that if Jordan
had not retired do they win seven in a
row or like day in a row it is so clear
when you watch that documentary in the
episode from Sunday he was shot he was
done I mean there was no chance of him
continuing he needed that break they
needed to change up the team go from
PacSun to kur from Horus ran to Rodman
they needed a change you're 100% right
by 99 I think they worry they used that
fuel of this is the last dance where to
the point where like they were not going
to come back fill his contract was a to
Jordan's contract without Pippen his
contract was up they were done so six
like out of eight is a fantastic run so
I hope this kind of when win when people
say what could have happened I I think
they maximize their potential Thank You
Josh preciate what do you got a question
for them Chris yeah Arash look you know
so much goat talk on Twitter right now I
can't take it anymore but who do you
think is the greatest ever Mike or MJ or
is it somebody else is a Kareem I I love
the debate I'm not one who doesn't like
it but it's Michael Jordan for
me in terms of what he meant for what he
did on the court and but but I really
hope we can just enjoy like everyone's
greatness at the like its own light like
like LeBron is great Kobe's great Kareem
Bill Russell like it doesn't have to be
a debate but when you watch Jordan just
like his presence and what he did on the
court I'm gonna go with Michael Jordan
but right now give it to LeBron what
he's been able to do and that's why I
really hope we do have a completion to
the seasons because if you were to win
under I mean there's gonna be a
documentary if the Lakers find a way to
win with what they've done from China in
the preseason which people forget to
Kobe in January to if they find a way to
win this year I mean what a crazy year
so the goat is Michael Jordan though
Chris Brockman I'm gonna have to give it
to Michael Jordan yeah I agree that's
that's a fact thanks to the caller Ross
really appreciate it that's a rush
mikaze of the Los Angeles Times
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here